Welcome to our talk
on R Markdown, RStudio
Connect, and R Shiny.
We're going to serve
you a three-course meal
today on how we automated our
data processing, error logging,
and alerts.
So it's time to meet the chefs.
My name is Kolbi
Parrish, and I'm
an informatics specialist
at the California
Department of Public Health.
I'm working there through UCSF.
Hi my name is Andy Pham.
I'm also working at the
California Department
of Public Health, also for UCSF.
So this talk was inspired
by a real-life event.
It was early 2020,
and Andy and I
were working at the
California Department
of Public Health within a
small informatics section.
And shortly after that,
the COVID-19 response
began, and our small section
was picked up and put
on to COVID-19 response,
where we remain today.
One of our main
charges was to prop up
data pipelines and products
to help inform the response
efforts.
And automation was a strategy
our team utilized early on
to help us be able to maintain
the scripts that we were
responsible for while
continuing to develop
based on the emerging needs.
But as the number
of scripts that we
were responsible for
grew and grew and grew,
sometimes some months it felt
like they doubled or tripled.
We quickly realized
that automation alone
wasn't enough to remain
responsive should anything
go wrong.
So a group of us got together
and started tossing around
ideas on how we could implement
additional strategies to be
responsive quickly
should anything go wrong
with any of our scripts.
And some of the strategies
that we came up with
were automated error-- data
processing, logging and alerts,
as well as a process monitoring.
So today that three-course meal
that we're going to serve you
starts with an appetizer of
how we automated our data
processing, followed by
a main course on error
alerts and logging.
And for those
Shiny lovers, we're
going to give you a taste of
Shiny in the form of a process
monitoring app at the end.
So the way that we automated
our data processing
was through a combination of R
Markdown and RStudio Connect.
We chose the import
from Git option that's
available on RStudio Connect.
And I'll tell you a little bit
about why we chose that option,
but it was really easy to use
because we store our code and Git
repositories.
And essentially
what we needed to do
was store code where we
were already storing it
and make sure we had
a manifest JSON file.
Grab that Git url, go
to RStudio Connect,
click on the content section,
click a publish button, and then
in a few steps we were able
to paste that URL that Git URL
into the screen and click a
couple additional buttons,
deploy our content, and we
had our automated scripts.
But one of the things that we
really liked about this import
from Git option was
that it not only
helped us automate our
scripts, but it helped
us automate our pipelines.
And that's because with
the check of a button,
we were able to say, any time
we make a change to our Git
repository, have
that code change auto
flow to that published content.
So great.
Now we have
automation, but imagine
one of those many automated
scripts result in an error.
How are you going to see what
error occurred and where?
Doing that can kind of be
like finding a single noodle
in a giant bowl of
messy spaghetti.
Just a little bit frustrating.
But error alerts and logging
are there to help.
The way that we
implemented that was
through a combination
of R Markdown, blastula,
loggit, and RStudio Connect.
So the process was really
similar for us to the way
that we automated
our data processing,
except we added in a
few additional layers
and those layers were logging,
email alert logic, and an error
report template.
And for us that was in the
form of an R Markdown document
which added some structure
to those email alerts.
So we started by calling
the loggit package,
and we chose the loggit package
because it made it really easy
to create custom
error messages as well
as add in additional custom
fields to the log messages.
And then we set up
our log path and this
helped specify where
we wanted the resulting
log files to be written to.
And then we had
the strategically
placed the loggit function
calls throughout our script.
And what we did is
we put a loggit call
at the start of each R
Markdown chunk upon error,
and we used the try catch
function to do this.
I'll show you an example
in just a moment.
And then at the end of
each R Markdown chunk.
It was really important for us
to, within our R Markdown scripts,
to name each chunk
with a unique name
because we then passed that
information back to the log.
So this is an example of
a loggit call upon error
using the try catch function.
And you see, in the event of
an error, we are calling loggit.
It was pretty easy to use.
This specific example is a
message, an error message type.
So that's that first
parameter there.
And then the next is
a custom error message
that we created use
using the paste function.
So we essentially can
put any text that we want
and then pass that error
message to that paste function.
And then the other
fields that were custom
that we found really helpful
to help us pinpoint exactly
where any issues were occurring
was the script name, the chunk
name, so the section of code
within a specific script.
And then we also like
to log attempt numbers
because sometimes there are
chunks of code that will
retry in the event of an error.
And then version
was another field
that we like to log because
it helps us determine
if the error occurred in a
production or a development
pipeline.
So the resulting log file looks
a little something like this.
You can see that we chose
to output a log file by day
and that was helpful because
we have a lot of scripts
and they're running
on a regular basis
and we have a lot
of log entries.
So this helped us be able to
quickly just kind of organize
things by day.
If you were to
open up that file,
it would look a little
something like this.
It is a JSON-based format, so
it doesn need to be parsed.
And Andy's going to cover how we
did that later on in the talk.
But you'll notice that
the fields that are logged
are similar to what you saw
in that loggit function call.
So that first one there
is an error message
and it's a log
level type of error.
You could also log things
like informational messages,
or warnings as well.
And then the next field there
is a custom error message.
And if we were to look at
the rest of the log file,
we'd find those
additional custom fields
like script name,
chunk name, and version.
So now that we have
our logs set up
and our logging
is happening, I'm
going to cover a
little bit about how
we implemented error alerts.
And it was relatively
easy to do by just adding
a little extra code at the end
of each R Markdown chunk
outside of the try
catch function.
And in the event of an
error, we essentially
use blastula to send out an email.
And so that
highlighted code there
shows the section of
code that will actually
render the email using
a specified error report
template.
That's the error
underscore report dot RMD,
and I'll show you what that
looks like in the next slide.
And once that's rendered, then
blastula then blasts it out
to the viewers and
collaborators that you specify
when you set up the automation.
All right.
So this is a screenshot of the
R Markdown error report template
that we use.
We like to keep it really
simple and just include
the information that we find
helpful to pinpoint exactly
where any issues occurred.
So that includes version, and
again that, for us, that
means development versus
production, the script
name, the chunk name.
So exactly where that error
occurred within a script,
the error itself.
And then we also like to
include a path to the full log
file just in case we want
to look at the history there.
So putting this all together,
how this works is we
have our script published
on RStudio Connect
and it's on the
schedule and it's
running on a regular basis.
We have our logging
integrated into the script.
We have that error alert
logic integrated, In the event
and an error, Connect will
essentially blast use blastula
and send out an email
to the specified viewers
and collaborators.
That error email
follows the template
that I showed you earlier
and looks a little something
like this.
This is just a dummy error
email that we set up.
But you see here the
version is our dev pipeline.
You see the script name, the
chunk name, the error itself.
And then we also have a
spot for the log path there.
So I'm going to
turn the floor over
to Andy to cover how we
took those log files that
were in JSON based format
and turn them into something
a little more digestible.
All right.
Thank you, Kolbi.
So now you have your
automated processes set up
and you have your email
alerts for error logging.
Now, let's say we get an email
saying that there's an error.
The next step is to
troubleshoot, right?
However, errors rarely
occur in isolation
in order to fix an
error efficiently
and to prevent it from occurring
again in future states.
We want to be able to find
if this error is occurring
in your development and
production environment.
Has this error occurred multiple
times throughout your processes?
And so before the process
monitoring app, what we would
have to do is we had to go
through the error and process
logs and as Kolbi mentioned before,
these are in JSON format.
And so and there's
probably hundreds
to thousands of lines
of this, so you'd
be pretty much
abusing your Control
F to try to find what errors
occurred and where it occurred.
And that's also not to mention
that, since we're logging almost
every day, we'd have to
go through all these files
to see if there's some kind
of historic pattern coming on
from these errors.
And so going through all
this, I would equate it
to trying to eat a
melting ice cream sundae.
Everything is mixed together.
Different ice cream
flavors are mixing.
And you might you're
tasting like two or three
different flavors.
You're not sure if
you like it or not.
It's very interesting.
However, our approach was
to season in some R magic
and make a more beautiful
ice cream sundae where
all the components
are easily seeable,
and you can get
to where you need
to be quickly and efficiently.
And so we did this with this
was our process for our process
monitoring app.
We took a bunch of messy
logs, applied some loggit,  R
Shiny, plotly, data tables,
any R visualization
packages, and turned
it into a dashboard
where we can view both how
our processes were doing
and the errors we got
within one single dashboard.
However, we first needed to be
able to read all of these logs
into something that
was R readable.
Fortunately for us, loggit
provides this function already.
There is a function called
read underscore logs where,
if you pass the path
of your error file,
it will read that error file
and return an R data table
that's easily filtered.
So now we could filter
based on if we wanted
to find an error and then by
which specific process and then
within a specific time frame.
So this was very
useful for putting up
the dashboard initially.
And so we fed this data
into a data table call
and built error data tables where
we could view all of our error
data's errors in relation to
each other, when they occurred,
and if they occurred
within any other processes.
We additionally fed our process
logs into another data table,
and because we had set up our
loggit calls within each R Markdown
chunk, we can now see how
long each R Markdown chunk took
within the process and
be able to identify
any bottlenecks as needed.
What we also did was we
also fed some of the process
log data into plotly.
And so we created this
graph where we could easily
be able to see how our
processes were doing in relation
to each other and in relation to
our development and production
environments.
We could also see if any
processes were running much,
much longer than we expected
so that we can get in there
and fix it before
anything broke.
And so we took all of these
different pieces, the error data
tables, the graphs,
and we put it
all into-- used R Shiny  to
put it all into a dashboard.
And so now we could
get what we needed
to be really quickly
and be able to see
on both of our development
and production errors
and processes in one setting.
And so the outcome
of this is that we
had all of our error viewing,
troubleshooting and process
monitoring in one
place, and we could
get to where we
needed to be quickly.
In addition, because
of R Shiny's sort
of user friendly
interface, we could
have new users on our
team be able to dive
into being able to fix
our errors without having
to know the intricacies
of our training system,
because we already
had an interface built
over that layer.
And so a new hires to
our team could also
start contributing to this
process monitoring app
again without having
to know too much
or spend too much time learning
about how our error logging
system works.
And so errors happen.
We're all human.
These are, we hope
these tools that we
and recipe that we have
made available to you today
help you be able to create
a full three-course error
friendly meal that's easily
digestible and worthy
of praise.
Thank you.